oh my god
my shoulders have been tense for the last
25 minutes citizens of the reject nation
we are here to watch house
of the dragon episode 4 today
i am loving this show so much how about you
john i am too enthralled i would say it's
probably my favorite thing on tv at the moment
yeah yeah that's an awesome good assessment i
might be inclined to agree with you
this is a good subjective assessment
anyway guys if you can leave a like i know you
can please go ahead and do that i mean a lot
also subscribe and click the notification bell get
notified when our reaction for the next episode of
house of the dragon is up here on this channel as
always following through action watch alongs where
you sync up with your own copy of house of the
dragon for our super sexy rejects at our patreon
page become a super sexy video today to check out
everything we gotta offer over there exclusively
lastly the team of prepper you guys rock thank
you for helping cut this down let's get to it
and though my seat may be less size
it is situated mostly 46 years later
a hundred years into the future
did you think my great-grandmother is beautiful
as they say this was half a century ago princess
yes it was i think i remember 50 year old women
she wins the crowd over with humor my princess
art is a bond that has long endured this is
lucas blackwood the grandson of my grandsire
aided the dragon in his war of conquest i the
blackwoods truly turn the tide on that one
your day shall be easy and night safe
under my protection protection
the princess has a dragon you dumb
i'm gonna like that one yeah
mary that guy over there craven
we're leaving oh i don't want to see this play
out yeah send words to the harbour and have
captain austin ready to ship princess in three
days i would happily roll myself back to king's
yeah man jokes don't get too far in westeros
what's going on are they being attacked
damon coming to visit oh [__]
is he got his hair tied up
straight up cut that [__] damn
add it to the chair
he's so freaking cool you wear a crown you also
call yourself king once we smash the trial key
they name me king of the narrow sea oh boy but i
know that there is only one true king your grace
well played
i wear this crown of crabs
upon my dragon chair hug
best goddamn reality tv i've seen in a while
so great at playing up the
tension of all their interactions
you only want my name in my valyrian blood for
their offspring i think it's rather romantic
how romantic it must be to get imprisoned
in a castle in me to squeeze out to ass
it's nice to see them kind of bonding
again i am glad you are home i find i have
a few friends baby i've missed you too
is said to have engaged in negotiations with the
sea lord of braavos he plans to wed his daughter
lena to the sea lord's son if house valerian
entered into an alliance with the free cities
we would have to seek our own marriage pact oh
god you better get on it man find the d game of d
you know just beat lord corliss
down there and marry him instead
wow
she's like princess jasmine
do an assassin's creed jump
this is her first time getting to really
see what it's like at night yeah i bet
he called me he called me boy our good
king names his daughter a girl his heir
oh my god have them all executed
do many of the focus that as small
everyone should be the heir yeah
their wants are of no consequence
you take care boy next time you might
not be so lucky enjoy that did you
who knows what our next takes freedom
i love it when they get along come
pardon me your grace the king
has requested your presence
oh i think i want to start making
another heir what is this place
it's where people come to take what they want
holy christ there is some stuff going on
oh my god
oh my god wow
i feel so conflicted
this squeamish sin of sexes
so i'm so uncomfortable
it's been a long time since i've had this
array of feelings to deal with during the show
jesse you just my pride i
shall allow the lord commander
my helmet
oh no she's got a taste of the fun
wow
bring back that dark messed up drumming music
the love of god
interesting correlation it's like they
have one of sexual depravity and now
one that actually seems sweet right
after almost doing it with their uncle
well yeah i'm like backed up against
a wall versus truly being together
yeah dude don't reject her it's
a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
this is such a process to get to get to the
action we do wear a lot of layers don't we
i like these like very realistic giggles she
has she's so great like in every type of moment
now go wait outside my door now stand watch the
rest of the night is she gonna get pregnant with
his kid i wouldn't put it past him the
master brings word from the white worm
ah crap god damn it i knew it oh no
come
that's great news for you otto i have
um discomforting news i thought it best
shared discreetly before the council convenes
i [__] the sea stake i'm afraid it concerns
the princess my king the flesh snake the
princess was spied last evening beyond the
walls of the keep in a pleasure house like that
take his hand so uncomfortable with her uncle
they were engaged in unbecoming of a maiden
of a princess my kids saw that what must i say
to you you enter my bed chamber accusing
my daughter of something i speak it plainly
have this rumor manga brought before
me at once and i will take their eyes
the princess creeping through the gates
from king's landing disguised as a page
during the hour of the owl oh my god was
this demon's plan the whole time yeah i bet
do you wish to have your blood on the iron
throne so badly that you are willing to
destroy my own leave me once oh that is pretty
crazy because otto they had that moment with
otto beforehand you see that he really
doesn't actually want to communicate yeah
like as much as you want to smack him i
do kind of feel bad just bring damon and
uh her in the same room
talk it out on the mori show
you are not the father princess
i have a message from the queen
my shoulders have been tense
for the last 25 minutes
your father accused me of something was i drank
wine if the castle after dark think you [__]
damn it in a pleasure house this is a vile
accusation you targaryens do have queer customs
and damon certainly knows no limit allison your
grace sister you must know i would oh my god yay
i used to see her like this
who made these claims to
your father i am the princess
to to question my virtue is an act of
treason that goddamn trees watching you
the old gods man david sank into his
cups and abandoned me for some haul
what's gonna happen
can't be the end of this i swear this
to you upon the memory of my mother
it was foolish of you to place yourself
in a position where your virtue could
even come into question says okay a little
bit of pot and kettle action there whatever
the king demands an audience take your hands off
oh my god thank god he's hungover
you better have a good matching story
he's still drunk oh i hope the stories line up
i feel like i'm watching an
alex garland movie i know
so twisted [__] up humanity when we were
near his age we way through most of the
brothels on the street of silk we were
young man she is just a girl your niece
there is a woman grown better first experience be
with me than somehow you have ruined her what lord
will wed her now in this condition because some
lord thinks you are the dragon your word is truth
and law i have spent a lifetime defending you
but your heart is even blacker than i thought
i should disinherit her if i already did
you be done with it waiter to me well
go back to the veil damon to your
lawful wife or don't matters not to me
as long as you are gone from my side for good it's
crazy there's like no violence in this episode
you believe he lied how often
does he speak the pure truth
how does confessing to such things
serve him by reducing you and your heir
monero is not innocent only because damon
tried to corrupt her damon renero she had
the blood of the dragon she swore to me
that she remains a maiden and i believe her
oh please don't be pregnant nine
months later from my blood come
the prince that was promised and his will be the
song of ice and fire your courtship is at an end
you will wed celeno valarion and you will do
so without protest the son of the sea snake
so i can be a remedy for your political
headaches you are my political headaches
like a mediator in here and what will you do
about the vulture who perches upon your throne
what vulture your hands yeah
he wants aegon to be named er
and he will stop at nothing to see it
done including spying on me to bring
about my ruin i will do my duties here and with
soleno but you must first do yours as king oh
how long did it take you to
choose yourself over your king
your grace will never recover from emma's death
but alison she was a calculated distraction
the queen loves you i made sure of it the crowd in
the realm both of you are dead can never be repaid
but i could no longer trust your judgment that's
crazy he told the truth and what that's so insane
all the [__] manipulation this guy did it was
the truth about that's how the karma comes around
that is nuts the ultimate irony i
took great care in its preparation
if not brewed properly it can
either prove ineffective or else
beautifully i'm sorry what is that it's like
a day after pill tea princess from the king it
will rid you of any unwanted consequences oh yeah
you haven't had the talk that must be very painful
oh my god i did it's a great shot to leave off on
too because like i wouldn't trust that but also
probably a good idea it was not fun that was that
was uncomfortable it was like a yeah it was like
some kind of action movie but instead of fights
just it's all discomfort and conflicting views
okay
yeah all right so this show is awesome this
is a terrific uh piece of television yeah
like we're back goddamn houses this is bold
that's it's like the characters are it's i love
how they're doing the time jumps because it's
not just so plot driven it's so cute it's like
so wildly character driven you just watch out
how these people just change over time and you
just got such different sides of everyone it i
felt like so many different directors influences
in this like tonal wise like there were parts
of it that reminded me of alex garland who did
stuff like ex machina annihilation and
then uh there are elements of it that
also kind of remind me of ari astor who films like
hereditary and mitsumar and uh i would also say
like i did a tinge of lars von trier yeah it's
just that sexual twistedness yeah yeah where
you know like i know the the the the religion
and deities that these guys worship is not like
christianity but like we grew up catholic
we're like sexual things and lust are very
very much they're frowned upon they're not looking
they're not look kindly upon just the thoughts and
it it was it was a fascinating look at it we're
like game of thrones it's kind of just like
the world of it just inhabits it you know and then
i did think it was actually kind of interesting
that when they did go to the brothel and
that's like the the cd underbelly of this world
that was just so much people just given in
to their their desires given into their their
bodily wants and such ultimate hedonism and
how it was captured in like a dark cringey way
well yeah it feels like you're watching like a
like a witch movie or something like that because
yeah it's like all these long shots robert eggers
in here too yeah cause you're looking through
fire and everything's lit by fire so you have
that sort of dancing strobing but also very dim
light just disassociates you with shadowy deeds
and yeah you're going through these narrow winding
streets and in through corridors and you're
watching a show and then you're in the pleasure
house and yeah like it feels very carnal it's so
much of uh yeah it's a good word for it carnal um
it so much of it seemed to be dealing with uh the
themes of when our desires have great consequences
yeah you know because so much of the time
you know especially with a character like
renera a lot of these characters too you know
it's not only the consequences but how our
how our desires of what we want to conflict
so much with the reality of what we have
and how that makes us feel yeah you know like
when it is cutting back and forth between like
this this lustful situation because they didn't
actually like go all the way right if i read that
scene correctly yeah yeah they didn't yeah that's
why she still needed more yeah yeah exactly yeah
they didn't go all the way so they went a further
they went enough yeah they went enough like oh my
god he definitely broke some firsts yeah uh so
they went they went enough but um because like
when they're cutting to there and then you're
even cutting to alison and there's so much about
you know how allison is serving her role and she's
just like surrendering her body you should be very
careful my words here because youtube sucks um
like surrendering her body uh to the situation
and you see that she is just not about it no no
not there yeah but it's it's it's what she she has
to do and it's like she's a young woman and i'm
sure she would probably desire some hot young stud
but this is what she has to do and then you're
watching how you know like allison is doing what
she has to do clearly not happy and then
you watch renera giving in to some desires
and she's enjoying it right yeah it's like
a if it's like i know the actress milli
alcock is is not a teenager um but i i'm so used
to her from being like a teenager yeah i was like
oh yeah i have to like work my brain around it
like especially when she's doing certain scenes
that you know she's not a teenager yeah she's
she's like actually in her 20s all right okay yeah
my mind has to kind of catch up a little bit
because i'm so used to seeing her in the frame
it's okay that discomfort is a
good thing it's a good thing yeah
yeah yeah otherwise you're like i
don't know if i want to watch this yeah
this seems unethical how is this on the
most popular network on television yeah um
but yeah as she's giving her uh her desires that
how she suffers the consequences for it or is
allison you know does it but either way it leads
to a life of suppressing what we really want and
being ultimately unhappy for it in the service of
duty and honor you know and having your autonomy
in that side of your life basically removed in
the interests of yeah your political uh worth or
you know yeah whatever you are to the king and
all that sort of other stuff that takes hold
like it's funny that people don't dog on this
show so much for like being woke because like
so much of this is about and they say it multiple
times like she was a young man no one would care
like she could go out and do whatever she wants
you know in the pleasure house or with anybody
with a family member whoever but because you're a
woman and in the position you are yeah it's like
people are gunning for you and you can't live
you know you can't get out there and live no
i mean maybe they don't gun for being
woke because of uh the fact that
she's just a super well written character and
the world didn't happen since mainly a lot of men
you know and so yeah i think that you know what
we saw renera go through in this episode was
so fascinating like when she started uh like
just a r i i i just admire the writing so
much like when she's talking to allison and
she gets into like she's been caught mowed
but she has to lie her way out of it she's
such calling her like you're grace sister
you know saying things i'm like she
doesn't she doesn't talk like this man
that's not a toxin she doesn't resort
to this you only like just started to
mend this bridge just getting desperate and and
then watching her lie um with such conviction
is not something that in the past like you feel
like you've gotten to know these people remarkably
well the time jumps yeah despite the time justice
fight that's only been four episodes that you
feel like you really know these people which is
such a testament to the show so to see her lie
is like oh i'm not i'm not you
that's not the rinner i know
i know her for being the one who says the
uncomfortable truths all the time and stands
up for what she really wants thanks you know
so to see her be put in that position and um
uh almost like borderline submissive to a
situation it's i gotta i don't know i gotta
process this episode i i don't wanna just
repeat the word uncomfortable kind of aches
you know it's a little bit of an achy feeling
i'm noticing in my heart like it's sort of
like twisting it well yeah because there's so much
they have a great i think blend of you know you're
there for part of it you see you know this sort of
i don't know it comes from multiple perspectives
because you know as you're i love the intercutting
and the contrast they draw in that scene because
at first i was like oh that's kind of random we
just cut back to allison but then the more times
they do that you you see yeah that contrast
and it's like you're there and in parts with
uh renera you know some of you is like yeah
get out there like you know go see the city
like you know you you live this life concerned
with things inside the walls of you know your
your your castle home but like really go see what
life is like and yeah you know you just go enjoy
some earthly pleasures it's a very human thing
but then to then realize that like okay a it's
happening with her her uncle and then b i don't
know what if he actually like they seem to have
a real rapport but then you're like well is he
just trying to use her to get under viserys's skin
and then you know you have the bit where alison
and rhaenyra kind of break the ice again after so
long realizing that they're both subject to this
system and both unhappy in various ways because
of it and then watching as that is effectively
kind of called into question and destroyed and
then you have like otto hightower who we've come
to this point of being like i don't really like or
trust this guy i love watching him and i love
risa fonz's performance and then this episode
you have him in arguably the most uh sympathetic
and and he's clearly acting or it would seem the
performance suggests he's acting out of integrity
at least in this isolated moment so it takes all
these things you know about characters and all
these ways you feel about them and it really plays
on and forces them in uncomfortable positions and
i feel like you know especially in the puritanical
world of the united states you know there's a
certain amount of like shame surrounded any sexual
conversation uh and so to see that rightfully so
as dirty you don't be ashamed you're going to hell
every sperm is sacred um but like that's already
such a kind of angsty faculty of life and then you
dump all these politics and yeah the warring
perspectives and the idea of like it doesn't
really matter what the truth is it just matters
how people perceive it and you get the whole thing
with the play and you already know this mounting
weight of like god the people in my dad's council
have their perceptions of me and they don't want
me on the throne and it seems like the common folk
don't and yeah it just draws this really painful
situation where yeah all you want is relief
and the characters seem to express this longing
for relief especially renera like i'd love to be
just without the constraints of my duty and and
my mantle and these things that have been thrust
upon me and the episode never gives you a moment
to breathe because yeah the whole time you are
just kind of tense oh my shoulders started to hurt
yeah yeah yeah i had this like tension just kicked
right in right by the sides of my neck yeah
it was just kicking in just so hard i'm like i
i'm not enjoying this but i can't stop watching
yeah and it's weird because it's like and you get
conflicted even in moments like or i did where i
like i love i love the back and forth that milly
alcock and matt smith have and i love especially
when they're speaking uh it's old valerian right
uh when they're speaking to each other in that way
and during that sequence i was like yeah you know
until they actually you know turn toward each
other in the pleasure house you know you're like
yeah i kind of like it when they hang out
they should spend more time to get like
you kind of feel that rush of you know freedom
through that and i'm like i like both these guys
and i like damon the most when he's hanging
with raniere and then yeah it twists it in
in a place we've been in game of thrones you know
lower before but yeah into something that is just
so uncomfortable and strange and and you know
he says that thing about like well you know why
not me why not somebody who she knows and who is
you know of royal blood and you're like i guess
for the time that's an argument but ugh like yeah
it just it it i think it plays on the fundamental
thing that we've all been through of you sneak out
you get some fun in you experience a little bit of
the world that's hitherto been kind of kept from
you and there is that russian catharsis but also
the immediate plunge back into consequences as you
know the people who are above you or who see more
of the picture than you do or have access to more
of the picture than you do then come and you know
uh reprimand and or shame you for whatever
it is and then you you know multiply that
by all the crazy state craft iron throne
circumstances and politics and stuff like that
that's all it is that's the game of
thrones right there yeah it's a fascinating
emotional interplay this episode
good for uh good for kristen though
good for sir kristin this is like the
the one guy who's kind of all right
well yeah i mean i think that's why they i think
they do a good job at flushing that out that it's
because it could have it could have just been
that that feeling of exploring the sexual
desires is a dark dark thing but it it shows
uh something kind of sweet and beautiful yeah
between the two of them something that felt
like they really are connected and there is a
genuine romance between them and i think the
show's done a good job on building up both
yeah this is stuff that's been percolating
throughout the years for these characters us
a few episodes but years for them right from the
first moment that you see in that first episode of
matt smith puts the necklace around rain era
it was like is there some type of thing yeah
i don't know i can't tell them maybe um i
suppose so and well now you look back and
you're like maybe yeah and then they're kind
of and they bring it back at the beginning with
the necklace too and it's so much about giving i
feel like that's probably what damon wanted was to
put up the card out there of let me marry
her like it's already gone to this point
but then he wasn't even going all the way there
so he even felt conflicted about it as well like
he kept pulling away and at first i thought it
was just some like act of like come get me yeah
and then it wasn't and he just straight up
abandoned her yeah and you could tell that
he was in his own head about the whole thing too
like i don't really know what damon's purpose for
returning is that's part of the complexity of his
character is that tug and pull of being and that's
what's so great about all these characters is
there's so many different things of what they all
no one's one note he he wants more he wants power
but he also wants connection he also wants family
with the with the people he's also combative with
you know there's so many things happening i think
going off of where the three episodes
prior were building what i love about
it is it seemed like the crumble would happen
externally from a war or some [__] like that
but really what's causing everything to crumble
is all within the castle and all within the family
family melodrama all the people who are living in
the hightower you know those are all that's where
everything is starting to um it's it like forming
like like this like a virus of insidious feelings
just taking over and then seeping through
everyone because everyone has desires and
everyone has wants and needs and and they all
have a certain direction they want to take so
yeah it's kind of cool watching
like rainer being sort of
like having to accept the positions he's in and
then willing to go through with the marriage but
you know feeling that need to also protect her
reputation as well uh it it was a really really
like messed up episode yeah i loved it yeah i i
loved it i loved it i love the uncomfortableness
because when they are going through the city i'm
like oh it's kind of like a jasmine thing and then
when they they're seeing the play i'm like oh it
must be about just trying to convince aegon to get
you know like hey you're probably better off
with aegon taking the throne you know i i
thought that's where the conversation was headed
was them debating about it i didn't think it was
going into this other this this very different
direction and uh with otto was that was great
that was that was excellent like they know how to
mess with you because you've kind of wanted him to
get exposed and he he did his job the way he was
supposed to well that's the thing too is i think
that contributes to that harsh feeling the episode
gives you as you're like as much as you want him
to be exposed it still pangs when you're like ah
but this isn't actually in this isolated situation
the right thing isn't happening for everybody
well he wasn't fired from being the hand for
lying yeah it was because of the thing raynera
put out there yeah you waited so long right now
you knew yeah you knew this whole time and then
she was waiting to dish that out save her ass
yeah i'm like you pulled the card at the
right time what's the other thing i think
they're really good at and and they're good
at drawing characters in a way where you can
no one is ever 100 one thing and that's makes for
compelling drama and mystery but they're good at
generally kind of depicting the characters who
are calculating and who have very long-term view
versus characters who like like i i love damon
partly because you always have to wonder like
i don't know if he really does have an in advance
plan half the time i feel like he just does
stuff on compulsion and because he is so minded
towards these things obviously they have political
cunning and ramifications to them but yeah they're
good at drawing those different boundaries between
yeah the very conniving characters versus the just
super impulsive characters and i feel like you
can kind of see that intersection with rhaenyra
especially well i think also with viserys that
speech that he gave to otto at the end it seemed
like it was a thing that he always kind of knew
sure you know you probably he he's a lot of these
people tend to go into denial about [__] and
they have to really suck it up in order
especially for king like yeah for viserys who's
constantly like i'm just trying not to
get everyone killed just trying to keep
everyone happy okay trying to keep things not
everyone protesting all the time like like i
know everyone's self-interested all right i get it
like i think we could do i sympathize for the guy
a lot of the ways you know um because
he's a great character there's so many
people just getting used and tossed around
and abused like alison used the pla he she
played the king but she was also being kind
of like [__] out by her father you know
and so in that moment of when when they're
having their intermingling at night i'm like
well you know they're married and i know
she's not into she's not doing anything
bad right now it's uncomfortable to watch because
she so doesn't just do it in because she has to
yeah um but you know he was under the impression
too that she was actually like really in love
with him and stuff and then it's just ever
you're just we're watching this viserys guy
just get [__] so hurt because you can tell
there's so much love in this guy's heart
like oh my wife doesn't really
love me she was just using me
and after about the wife who really did love
me died in a terrible tragic death where my son
died my own daughter i'm trying to keep this
[__] in order now she's banging my brother
this is so all over the place and he's just you
we're watching this dude just deteriorating yeah
not only that but my daughter refuses to let
me help her because he seems still like you
know committed to having her be the heir
and it's like oh you're not helping me man
yeah whoa he's he's a great character too like
like props to patty considine because i feel
like it would be easy to make a character like
this feel just like a dope but uh especially for
he's aware of a lot yeah yeah yeah and i feel
like we've had kings similar at least briefly
in other game of thrones seasons where you're like
ah yeah this guy's not made for this world at all
um and and viserys while there is a lot about
him where i'm like yeah i mean you're not gonna
be the most sung about targaryen king like
yeah the the complexity with which they draw
his pitfalls as a character versus the moments
of strength i think are really compelling and
everybody testament to the casting everybody and
him as well like there's so much in the faces and
so much in the performances along with the great
writing that like yeah i just can't take my eyes
off of him and rinero is going to be marrying um
the son of poreless i believe who is the that is
the husband of what not it's not written here
over here uranus or something like that because
i've been wondering where she's been and and
having them have scenes together again it's like
oh damn them getting married it just it shows
like venera is not winning that argument that
she was having audrey's yeah yeah clearly yeah
oh well and i mean imagine what they're gonna
have to talk about when she gets there uh
yeah i love it it's uh it's so messed up
i enjoy it so much rich it's dark but rich it's
like a it's like a it's like a 97 dark chocolate
because like the first three episodes were like
there were some real like horror especially in the
first episode it's truly horrific birthing scene
um but for the most part the show has been like
dark messed up but fun yeah and
this is the crab feeder stuff yeah
so entertaining and and this one this episode was
so dread heavy yeah and so much of a of a build in
in a way that felt more play like like a play yeah
and then um you know some extravagant expensive
tv show it was very very very beyond intimate
and not indulgent in because sometimes you know
what these shows are like when you know today we
need to do the fun stuff and then hear them like
that's really sort of a twisted purpose this time
yeah real twisted purpose oh yeah and i mean that
was a funny thing they said before the season
like we're not going to do as many gratuitous
uh lovemaking scenes and this episode certainly
has a lot of flesh on display but it does
feel more like it is there for a direct
purpose than just being like we're hbo'd we can
uh well yeah i mean i think i think it
just finally clicked with me now way
late in this conversation of it it does
emit that feeling of like you know if if
people are participating in such group activities
there's nothing technically wrong with that
uh it's it's really the fact that through her
perspective you know through the position she's
in it's wrong for her to be there yeah you know
um and it's so far beyond anything that she's
usually subject to like i can't say no to this
and this is not gonna lead to something good yeah
so yeah i liked it it felt like threatening one
two like really great use of both music and sound
design because especially during that sequence
where they're out in the city and they're headed
towards the pleasure house there's that there's
that passage where the music even gives way
to just this like unsettling harsh ringing tone
that just gets louder and louder and louder as
this is all happening and and that really kind of
struck me on like a i don't know deep down sort of
primordial level and it does feel like that kind
of haze that comes on when you are in a risky
situation like that and you are kind of losing
innocence and you are sort of in between the
margins of acceptability and danger and all sorts
of stuff like it it really as much as like what's
on the page and what is acted is really effective
they're also really good at transporting you in a
tonal sensory way without yeah needing to be like
hey you know like this episode is so human in so
many ways and that's partly what i think makes
it feel so harsh and so conflicting because it
is all in there you don't need a dragon or a or
a zombie creature or a big battle or something
you know to hit that you know you just need the
real margins of humanity and then multiply it by
the time and place that we're in but yeah yeah all
right guys well um what'd you think of the episode
leave your thoughts down below uh subscribe and
leave a like and he will end this with a patreon
anisa oliva niece we are typing in what your
name means oh here we go here we go oh my god
this is too long yeah man
he wants to read all that
novel about anissa all right thanks for being
here we love you all right here we go cool anisa
beautiful girl true contest sometimes crazy
but as but fun as hell to be around true
so true one time i saw her rob a bunch of
homeless children yeah they had it coming
admittedly it was like what are you doing but
surprisingly led to a lot of laughter it was
crazy but it was fun as hell loves attention
she vlogged the whole thing you can look it up
it's amazing selling copies surprisingly sounds
offensive but actually really funny you got to
see it rides the line um shy at times oh yeah
totally i mean approaching those homeless kids
took it it takes a little bit occurred it's like
an hour yeah it's not easy talking to homeless
kids no you know relate to the homeless kids near
like i just don't understand like what that is
very sweet but can be mean when she has to be yeah
like when she's shaking down homeless kids yeah i
mean but you know mean when she has to be yeah and
frankly you gotta do it for the abuse incredibly
sexy oh yeah oh my god yeah those homeless kids
were thirsting loyal and uh intelligent her
body is to die for so many of them broke puberty
that day yeah she is bootylicious oh dude dude the
boot wow the scoot the hemisphere it encompasses
yeah is so just perfect circumference goes through
the imagine lines and you put the pencil in the
paper wormhole dude flat circle every guy seems
to be drawing her and not just because of her
amazing ass ets she's more than just her butt
that's for sure man true she's got a bit of a
brain but the butt is is a is a strong detail
she can be feisty oh yeah dude total [__] at
times but man so hot god anisa oh dude you you do
be a feisty you wanna be [__] you can get away
with that anisa because you're so bootylicious
but that's one of the many reasons why you will
love her because she's not actually a [__]
yeah it's true because she's easy to talk to she's
easy to talk to she's funny she's honest and has
a beautiful smile and a big heart again huge ass
definitely someone you don't want to lose that's
true we have to lose that ass we don't want a
loser she's a tough warrior woman who was also
hilarious authentic and just so natural you
know and ask for a better friend than just so
natural so natural oh natural i'm just like that's
the word to describe no preservatives natural no
process people are always like foods natural
in what way i'm like you know what i mean yeah
natural 100 organic and then i was like you need
to elaborate more repeating the word natural does
not tell me more about what a niece is natural at
or in or about i'm like look here's how i would
describe it natural natural it's in her nature and
frankly that's why she had to step in and be at
those homeless kids because they just kept asking
too many questions yeah you know yeah it just got
in the way and she just naturally stepped in and
dealt with it took care of those homeless kids man
that's right those homeless kids who never
really got their due that day into the ass
thanks anisa oh give me bread shut up i
don't have bread i think i just walk around
with bread on me yeah what do you think
this is this is oliver twist right now
what what century are we in someone's gonna
comment i'm a homeless kid that's offensive
like what you're doing with the phone
you're homeless dude what are you at
the library right now what's going on your
youtube account you're smarter than this
you should you should be out there
making a living if you're capable of this